i want to start with congratulations on
making your first feature um i know
you've been in the dga for i think over
20 years and um so it you know it
happened really quick yeah you know how
it goes bro you stand in line long
enough they'll notice you i guess
you've worked as a stunt coordinator
you've done so much in the industry um
how many i guess can you talk a little
bit about some of the things you've
learned along the way or seen directors
do that you sort of have been like
writing down to make sure happened on
your movie anything you see or do in
your life will influence you you can't
see something and not influence you you
can't it's just impossible once you've
seen it or been a part of it and i would
tell you i have equally learned from the
masters that i've got to work with
um
you know some of the amazing directors
i've learned equally as much from the
directors that were first and second
time directors sometimes it's what not
to do sometimes it's what to do
um
i my whole mantra for the action in my
movie was not to do anything that i'd
done before
or if i did something i did before to to
spin it
we shot the movie in 42 days with no
second unit in the middle of a pandemic
so it was it was a big it was it was a
big appetite with not a lot of times we
had to run and gun
i used a second unit mentality to the
pacing of how i shot
three cameras averaging 50 to 60 setups
a day
but when it comes to the comedy it's not
like action you can't rush comedy like i
beat the action i i whip the action
with the comedy you have to let that
happen you have to be there and be
president and give them a an opportunity
to succeed so i learned something very
important from paul feig on a movie
called spy that i worked on years ago
where he would keep it rolling and he
had these uh
accordion of post-it notes with uh alts
that he would write down
and when you have someone like jamie
foxx and dave franco who are directors
as well
um
throw in the heat the comedy heat a lot
of times all i have to do is
is just
get out of their way say action you know
and then okay one more time a little
more energy keep it moving so i i would
say paul feig had a lot of um
influence on he was really pretty much
the only comedy that's the only comedy i
think i worked on i worked on a lot of
comedies but they weren't meant to be
comedies but that was the only comedy i
worked on was supposed to be a comedy
but i learned because i really paid
attention to what he did
and then um
you know i because i came up with chad
stachowski and i helped him with wick
one and wick two i was there with him
when he was going through that
you know i watched some of the things
that worked for him as well
i like to use three cameras always and
in car chases i'll use seven or eight
but when i'm shooting dialogue in action
i'll use three
sometimes too many cameras you get in
your own way you know sometimes not
enough cameras it takes too long so
you know there was something i picked up
from everyone like
you can't like i said you can't do
something
in your life and it not influence you
whether it be a good influence or bad
influence or you don't use it or do use
it but it's ingrained in you because
you've seen it i love the opening fight
between jamie and the grandmother
vampire uh it's excellent um can you
sort of talk about uh filming that
sequence and because um you know it's
very practical this isn't some cgi thing
no we we did everything in camera when i
learned this business was in 1990 when i
got out of the army you couldn't just
say we'll fix it in post
and a lot of the movies i work on as a
second unit director
i pass on movies that are blue screen
movies i prefer to be out there like
fast and furious we're out there
wrecking 300 cars
locking up edinburgh scotland flying
jumping off a bridge we're doing it i
love that that's what i signed up for
that's the business i learned how to do
and it's a dying art
um but that fight in particular so you
know
the grandma
uh audrey's daughter there was an
actress that played the character there
was a stunt double that we put on we
wrecked through things there was a fight
double for all the intricate fight work
then there was a contortionist double so
there were four different players in
that sequence for them that set was
built
by my production designer based on a
previz that i had done before so one of
the things that i did was i i galvanized
all my departments because a lot of
times when you're making movies you have
25 departments and they're all doing the
same movie but they're all off doing
their own thing so there's a little you
lose a little bit from everyone because
of lack of communication i knocked that
wall down and i made sure we all my
vision was that one of the big mistakes
that i want that i see young directors
make is they don't share their vision
like they know what they want but they
don't explain it well enough like you
have to almost over explain it so
everyone and use visuals i got all my
department heads all in on that
and all the reactionary work whenever
you saw the the the grandma folded up
you can't smash a contortionist in that
position you'll break them
we put them in that position and then we
pulled them out on a wire and played it
in reverse
uh with a magic frame rate that i cannot
disclose unless you send me a check for
ten thousand dollars but that was part
of the you know the old school
filmmaking process that i learned i
didn't invent contortionist i didn't
invent reverse photography but i did
help i felt like we brought in
weaponizing and reactionizing the
contortion work was fresh and new i felt
like it's very visceral when people see
a woman getting wadded up in half like
that especially an older woman everybody
cringes and that's exactly what i was
hoping the audience would do you
mentioned chad and uh he's a producer on
the movie um there is an element to the
film that it's like it's
it's there's a i don't want to say it's
john wick with vampires but there's a
john wick esque thing to it with the
with the union and the vamp like you
know what i mean can you sort of talk
about that aspect because it it's not
just um there's a richer world if you
will
understood so what i got i was getting
after john week two i was getting a lot
of scripts like i said when i got day
shift it spoke to me because i
understood the world that hides in plain
sight from john wick it really works i
love the idea of that i go through that
door and there's a bunch of secret
agents in there throwing knives then i
go out that door and there's people
repelling then i go out that door it's
the lobby they'll tell them like i think
that's cool what you don't see the
things that can hide in plain sight with
day shift why i loved it so much is you
have the union
of hunters and then you had the vampire
so you had two worlds that hide in plain
sight and the vampires which can elevate
it when when you're dealing with humans
you're bound by
gravity and human-ness as soon as you
introduce vampires you can go reality
plus 80 and it it's totally viable
so that's why i really leaned into that
and i was hoping no one would hope would
think it was john wick with vampires
because i wanted to be a different kind
of funny like lost boys or
or fright night or big trouble little
china those are the movies that i really
really loved
i wanted the action to be super fun and
cool
sometimes cruel but most of the time
cool
and uh i was really counting on the the
the suspense elements to keep people you
know in their seats shifty in their
seats so
you know i'm just super grateful that i
got to do it and and and work with all
these gems it was it was a real it was a
real career highlight for me yeah by the
way it's not john wick with vampires i'm
just saying that that that one aspect of
like the the richer world you know what
i mean 100 right
you saw it exactly and that's what
that's what spoke to me because i needed
something like that but i didn't want a
copy because i got like hey do another
john wick thing we'll get uh this guy
and we'll you know we'll make this guy
the next john wick i'm like yeah but we
already did that we already did gunjitsu
we already invented gunjitsu we can't do
that again we got to find something else
and that's why i was looking and as soon
as day shift showed up it really spoke
to me uh i really hope it's a huge hit
for you and um i wish you nothing but
the best
dude thank you so much bro i appreciate
you i'm glad you liked it man i really
am